this is an amazing story right here CNN
politics Hunter Biden calls for criminal
probe and aggressive new legal strategy
this is my favorite this is my favorite
thing favorite anything here right they
say uh the allegations made in letters
to the Delaware attorney general uh the
Justice Department's National Security
division in the IRS marked the first
time President Joe Biden's son and his
legal team have publicly acknowledged
that it was his personal data purported
to be found on a laptop left at a
Delaware repair shop let me just come
out and say hunter Biden thinking he's
going on the legal offensive says he
wants a criminal probe into the laptop
and even CNN was like wow he admitted it
was his now here's the best part they
came out I don't know if I actually have
here we go yeah from Jackie Heinrich
attorney for Hunter Biden tells me
letters requesting investigation into
the laptop repair store owner Julian and
others are not acknowledgment the laptop
is in fact Hunters which makes no sense
because if it's not his then he's not
the victim
if it's not it's not the victim
so so so then he's got by the way he's
not a victim anyway because it's Salvage
law
well I guess the argument he's trying to
make is and they've long made this is
that maybe the laptop was uh someone
hacked as data put on a laptop and then
dropped it off there to to trick
everyone at this point conspiracy at
this point that laptop that hard drive
that we were going through in October of
2020 when Steve Bannon handed me and
Rahim a copy of that thing and said have
at it boys that uh not a single person
has been able to come through and find
anything that was changed that was
altered that was added that was edited
not once and by the way this isn't just
like a copy of files it's an actual
clone of his laptop from that period of
time well it was his actual laptop yeah
and then copies of the hard drive were
made that's right so I mean you're when
I when you you actually need a um you
need a Mac OS from that time frame in
order to even boot the thing yeah that's
how much of a clone it is did you have
any games on that laptop or if you don't
have to if you're not allowed to answer
then you don't have to answer that's not
something
well the crazy thing is uh is that
there's so much information still on the
laptop that's not been released and it's
because people don't know what to look
for
so when a story comes out like the
classified documents right then people
go let's search for this information and
see if we can find anything oh hey wow
there's emails so well it's also like
you you get more information and then
because there's a lot of it because it's
it's you know you're getting chains of
emails but you don't always get the star
at the end Etc or you see names and some
of these people aren't necessarily
mentioned in in press so you're not sure
exactly who it is and you have the
ability to take lead on it but again
it's it's just someone's personal laptop
so there's thousands and thousands of
emails on it so what uh what happens is
exactly what you just said that
something happens in the real world and
that gives you new context to go back
and look at the exact same thing that
you had seen a million times before but
then realize what it is there's a ton of
emails on the laptop and if you don't
know what you're looking for you're
seeing static like on TV but if someone
points out hey Hunter Biden lived at
this house and they were classified
documents here someone says okay let me
search the database and see if these
keywords come up whoa they did
you don't even know what to look for
until you know what to look for you know
what I mean what so so they're not
calling for a lawsuit though they want
he wants a criminal probe so are they
gonna they're gonna send the doj after
you Jack
greater men than you have tried yeah
what's the pro ball what's a criminal
pro ball about what would that entail
and what's the purpose no like I guess
they're arguing maybe like Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act or something
December like they're seeing if there's
enough there
well by the way and I'm just gonna say
publicly that what IO whenever we booted
this thing up there was something I said
from day one I said do not connect this
thing to the internet don't connect it
not one second because I don't and I
don't even know but his Apple ID is
associated with that thing then if you
connect this to the internet which I've
never done then if it starts syncing
let's say his Apple ID hasn't changed it
starts syncing now you're in violation
because now you're downloading new
information that was not left with
Johnny MacIsaac at that store and by the
way chatted with lawyers etc etc about
all of this uh extensively and and that
was sort of the the point was that
anything that was left the store was
left yeah there's so many copies of this
laptop floating around now it's crazy
yeah I hear from like random people
they're like oh yeah our news team's
doing and I'm like wow much like to be
Hunter
you know look uh don't get cracked out
don't your laptop yeah don't don't smoke
crack and leave your laptop lying or
which I I love that story that um if you
remember early on there were a bunch of
like you know journalists saying well
that that story of that and Rudy
giuliani's never made any sense of me
you never heard of a crackhead losing
something
story I could think of I wouldn't be
surprised if he's also Rich he didn't
care about the laptop so when it broke
he probably just was like
you know I'm not gonna go and pick it up
I don't know I got other things to do
forgets about it and someone's like you
ever go get your laptop back I don't
know I'll stick the data on my new
computer one of the big angles that I've
I've always he could have just forgotten
too and thought he lost it looking
around for his laptop the next day what
could I do with that thing
um and then just goes and buys a new one
because he thinks he lost it something
that I do want to bring up though
because we've been talking about the
potential for foreign influence we've
been talking about how our country has
owned all of the information that we
have on that laptop all of the the data
all of the voicemails the talks of the
Chinese Communist Party the deals with
barisma the Ukrainian energy firm who
just had their uh their former owner the
money guy behind it the oligarch Igor
karlamoisky was raided this week by the
government of Ukraine so they're clean
they're cleaning up Loose Ends over
there
that guy had been a huge backer of
zielinski by the way as well in his TV
show and his campaign he was just rated
so you know GA is is is tying up Loose
Ends but the
when I think of this and I compare it to
sort of like a dossier that we would see
in the IC that this isn't a dossier or
if it is a dossier this is the dossier
that Hunter Biden had on himself right
this isn't something that an
intelligence uh organization would put
together so imagine what
Eastern European intelligence Services
have on Hunter Biden from what he was
doing there that even he didn't save
imagine what the Chinese Communist Party
the ministry of the insecurity second
Bureau has on this guy because this is
the stuff that he wasn't filming himself
saving himself recording himself what
was the stuff that was too hot for
Hunter Biden to even put out there right
so that's what they have on him and I
think I think at this point what we're
really seeing and it's it's you know
it's an interesting
story to get into but it's it's the
power of the Biden family is over
they're pretty much dying they're
they're spent and they're going to take
they're going to take old man by no
banjo and they're gonna hold them by the
liver spot at hand they're going to give
them a glass of warm milk and maybe some
you know mashed peas and Brussels
sprouts and they're going to walk them
out the front door and then get Sprouts
are a little too hard for old you know
we'll steam brussels sprouts yeah my
mommy system they're very Sprouts are
good actually yeah you know like I like
them stem grilled then they're going to
walk them out of the White House he's
done they'll send them off to Rehoboth
the son of a woman whatever you know I
hope it's nice
um and they are going to prepare and
then Kamala just forget about that um
we're talking about and they're going to
pave the way for Mr hair gel Hitler
himself Gavin Newsom hair gel Hitler how
would you rate him on a scale of one to
a hundred just quality wise and what 100
is good or bad 100 is the best who's
excited about him one like the best
really I think he's the worst well I
think
I think the regime the GAE wants a new
Once knew fresh blood and so what's
interesting though is for Gavin Newsom
is that his biggest problem is going to
be getting through the Democrat Southern
primaries because he doesn't have any
put it this way he doesn't have any
intersectional Pokemon points
um he's a straight white male who's
married to a straight white female and
they have have white children so there's
no intersectional Pokemon point so he is
Hitler basically right so obviously
Hitler so hair gel Hitler on the other
hand he's got to think of something to
appeal to those voters in the Democrat
primaries in Georgia and South Carolina
and what's California talking about
right now what's the California Council
that he just instituted reparations yeah
that's exactly so he's going to campaign
and he's going to use this as a national
platform to say I was the first state in
the nation to provide for there's
already some cities in like San
Francisco and others that's bribery he's
got yes it is what
this is going to be his National
platform right and it'll benefit him
that so many people fled California they
didn't leave their uh favoritism for him
behind they just moved to Southern
States I think we should talk about the
uh the historical racism of the Japanese
internment camps right and how that
affected all uh people from from the
Asian diaspora and their and their
relatives and how uh they're deserving
of reparations too that's right yeah
that's right so here's I would like this
is for 100 000 this is the take on on
reparations that and and it's it's not
even to get into the question but if you
have if you have the US government
handing out 25 000 checks to one group
of people and nobody else you're gonna
tear this country apart at the seams
yeah this is tear this country apart and
this is what I talk about the problem
with this uh leftist racist psycho
psychotic ideology that you have you
have a neighborhood on the south side of
Chicago that is predominantly black but
it's only like 90 percent and then you
have Latinos and white people and it's
lower income and then the government
comes in and gives out checks to only
the black people yep like that that's
gonna cause a lot of problems yeah like
it's going to cause crazy like I mean
the gangs are going to go off for one
but people are gonna get pissed off well
and then first thing the gangs are going
to do is go run to everyone who got that
check and go start collecting checks
that's right I mean you're gonna you're
gonna see and look taxes are due I lived
through and by the way I appreciate you
the shout out the other day on on when I
I'd written that story about my home oh
yeah man losing my my right I did a
whole thing about it we had a great we
had a great town and the house I was
born in was something like 84 years old
by the time I uh it was there was the
house my father grew up in and that was
what you did and everybody knew
everybody the kids I played with were
the children of the kids that my dad
played with when he was a kid and on the
same block on the same town uh there's
about you know eight miles out of
Philadelphia just just a regular normal
Northeast you know kind of
quasi-industrial town and that picture
that's on the article is is my house
that from when we left it or you know
kind of a little before we left to where
it is today and it's just it's it's you
know it's it's
bad 2000 Pizza Hut nationalism man what
happened it's a crime just just it's all
crime it's all crime
um it became a sanctuary City for uh for
Mexican IDs when that was a big thing in
like 2002 the hospital shut down uh
people the hospital I was born in was
was uh destroyed and raised to the
ground now because the company that
bought it and realized that they'd never
make any money there so they shut down
the hospital the homicide rate has gone
up like crazy uh rapes violent crime et
cetera et cetera it's just just spiraled
into this this CD uh Town that's that's
you you can go back and you have these I
have these great memories of growing up
there but then even
you know my brother and I were sort of
chatting it about it after I wrote this
thing that this is Norristown
Pennsylvania
um that if you you know we we remember
right remember the dog fights that were
going on in the Audi when we were trying
to learn how to ride bikes and the drug
dealer is getting arrested every week
but then they'd be back every week and
nothing ever seen having the cops there
all the time
um my mom used to let us walk to the
library which was a couple of blocks
down but then uh homeless people kept
stabbing each other there wow so uh we
weren't allowed to do that anymore and
uh I remember my brother told me a story
I wasn't there but he said he remembers
looking out the window one day and they
were just looking across the street
these two guys were just like just just
beating each other up like right there
on the street in like the middle of the
day kind of stuff and this was going on
and on you couldn't have a bike or you
might just kept getting stolen uh and it
just kept getting worse and worse and
worse and finally I finally got us out
and the house is beautiful house is
absolutely gorgeous three stories
um you know my mom said that if we if we
could have taken it with us us we would
have because it was so nice to grow home
but it's it's that that story isn't
unique to me and I'm not special for
having lived it but it you have this
happen to communities all across the
entire country and I think I think we
misuse the word Community you know we
say you know we say like we talk about
it at like a racial group or an ethnic
group or a gender group now or a trans
Community but but our community a real
Community is people that have known each
other that have bonds of familiarity for
that go back Generations they used to go
to church together yeah somebody super
chatted uh asking if I knew that they
paid reparations to Japanese internment
camp uh families I knew that absolutely
that's why I said Asian diaspora Asian
diet he was making a point my point is
that um when it comes to the reparations
in places like California how do you
know how are you going to go through and
make sure every single person is a
descendant of of someone who is enslaved
and then are you really going to follow
through because that means there will be
many white people who will Trace lineage
back to you know a great great
grandmother or father who was black and
then are they entitled to you know to
this so my grandmother is high
cheekbones so if the natives are
involved well who's who's that uh who's
that famous actor
um he's he's he what's his name Mel
Brooks what I just know the guy from
prison break we're just watching you
know what I'm talking about the other
day the guy the guy from prison break
he's also Captain Cold in the uh The
Flash show I forgot his name but um he's
I think he's like one eighth black but
he just looks like a white guy yeah like
is he gonna get Wentworth Miller there
you go there you go yeah he does good
work I like uh I like stuff he said he's
Captain Cold I dig that stuff I like DC
or does he only got one eighth no but
like no just get one eighth of the check
no I I get it but like what's gonna
happen when like there's a line full of
people walking up to get their checks
and there's a bunch of white people that
are getting the checks and they're like
wait what's going on it's like whoa then
there's gonna be also a bunch of black
people who are like Nigerian immigrants
or Haitians exactly what I'm saying San
Francisco is has this reparations
committee what do you mean like Kamala
Harris and Barack Obama
exactly they should get a check man they
were they were affected but San
Francisco San Francisco has their
operations committee and they put forth
this idea like you'll give uh it's five
million dollars for each black resident
of San Francisco and you have to have
either prove that your uh connected to a
you're the tenant of a slave or that you
emigrated to San Francisco during a
certain time period and then also the
California was never a slave state yeah
right California was a free state that's
right the whole time
admit it as a free state except for the
Chinese well yeah right yes well as I'm
saying by Asian diaspora you know I and
and the reason I say that is because
people couldn't tell the difference back
then you know my family was oppressed by
the the white supremacy yep patriarchy
system
you got to give me money yeah where's my
money give me that I agree I don't think
it's I don't think it's possible to
solve technically and I also don't think
that throwing money at people is the way
to help them necessarily I mean a little
bit if you have zero you know you give
them having a thousand is a lot
different than having zero it's a big
difference from going to one thousand to
two thousand like once you get out of
zero that's something but on top of that
like where what are we repairing but Ian
you tell me you're assuming that the
people pushing this stuff actually care
about solving a problem I think they're
trying to bribe the constituations
that's not a solution I'm okay I'd like
to say that they say no if you teach a
man to fish you know you feed them for a
day I'm sorry if you give a man a fish
if you feed him for a day teach your
manifest your feeding for the rest of
your life and then they also people say
you got to pick yourself up by your
bootstraps picking yourself up by your
bootstraps requires you have boots yes
and teaching someone to fish if they're
really going to feed themselves for the
rest of their lives they need a fishing
pole so there's gotta there's somewhere
that's not it's you know well I don't
know about cooking a fishing pole they
need a fishing but right you can't be
like here's how you fish good luck
finding a fishing pole because they're
gonna be like yo I can't fish unless I
have one of those things you can
Spearfish I guess make one out of a
stick and then pick yourself up by your
bootstraps you gotta have boots to do
that so my attitude is kind of like can
we provide the the means for
self-sufficiency but then require
self-sufficiency like we're not going to
feed you tomorrow we're going to tell
you how you do it and then it's up to
you like we're gonna we're gonna give
you the tools you need to do it it seems
like the only sustainable way if I was
playing a game and that was one of my
options that would be the only feasible
Way Forward would be to pray that people
would figure out how to sustain
themselves if you give them a little bit
once that's the only way I mean this was
the same argument that was made for the
general amnesty in 1982 6 when Reagan
went for it that you know we're going to
deal with this once a little bit and
then it'll go away that we're just going
to give a little bit of amnesty and then
we'll never have an illegal immigration
problem again that was Ronald Reagan
that was 1986. California has never been
read again and he also is the gun
control guy and no fault divorce guy so
anyway thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time